إنه لأمر رائع أن أكون معك موثقة جيدًا
العلاقات الحميمة للرئيس ترامب مع فلاديمير
بوتين ، فأنت تعلم ما
هي غرامة بوتين هذه المرة ولكن بينما
وصفت تدخل روسيا مرارًا وتكرارًا
في انتخابات عام 2016 بأنه خدعة ، فإن
الرئيس الأمريكي يمنح بوتين انتصارًا واحدًا في
السياسة الخارجية بعد حظر التسهيلات التالية.
الكرة الأرضية بأكملها تقريبًا في
الشرق الأوسط ،
سوريا ليست سوى أحدث حالة من
تراجع أمريكا وتدخل روسيا في
القوات الروسية التي تقوم الآن بدوريات في شمال
شرق ذلك البلد بعد أن
تخلى الرئيس ترامب عن حلفاء أمريكا
هناك وأجبروهم الأكراد
على السماح لروسيا بدخول
المنطقة التي نحن فيها.  لم يوافق أبدًا على حماية
الأكراد لبقية حياتهم ، أصبح
بوتين الآن الرجل القوي الجديد في المنطقة
حتى حلفاء الولايات المتحدة التقليديين مثل المملكة
العربية السعودية والإمارات العربية المتحدة وفقًا للكرملين ،
حيث يقوم بوتين بتقديم عرض مبيعات
للمعدات العسكرية الروسية بدلاً من المعدات الأمريكية التي
تستخدم بشكل جيد.  المواد الكيميائية لبيع هذا
السلاح ، تحتاج القيادة السعودية
فقط إلى اتخاذ القرار الحكيم  تمامًا
مثلما فعلت إيران عندما اشترت s-
300 ومثل اه دواوان عندما اشترى
لنا بالمئات ، فإنها ستحمي أي
بنية تحتية سعودية وبينما أظهر الرئيس ترامب
القليل من الاهتمام بأفريقيا ،
يضع
هوتن الصحافة الدبلوماسية الكاملة مع
وقع قادة القارات روسيا اتفاقيات
تعاون عسكري تقني
مع أكثر من 30 دولة
حيث نوفر مجموعة كبيرة من
الأسلحة والمعدات ،
وفي الوقت نفسه في أوروبا ، كان الرئيس
ترامب ينفر حلفاء الناتو
القدامى ، واصفًا التزام أمريكا
بسلامتهم بالتشكيك ،
واحتجز الرئيس  دعم المساعدة العسكرية
لأوكرانيا التي تواجه تمردًا مدعومًا من
روسيا تضغط على
الرئيس الأوكراني للتحقيق مع نائب
الرئيس السابق جو بايدن ونجل بايدن
مما يؤدي إلى تحقيق المساءلة في
الكونجرس.لا يوجد دليل على
ارتكاب جو بايدن أو ابنه مخالفات. أنا
مهتم فقط بالفساد.  لا
أهتم بالسياسة أنا لا أهتم
بسياسة بايدن حتى في أمريكا اللاتينية
ica نفس النمط بينما يبدو أن الدعم العام الأمريكي
للرئيس المؤقت لفنزويلا خوان جيدو قد
تضاءل الرجل القوي نيكولاس مادورو
لا يزال في السلطة
حيث يظل دعم روسيا له
ثابتًا في إرسال رسالة واضحة إلى
عالم أمريكا وتراجع
وفلاديمير بوتين.  أجاب الفراغ
في سي إن إن موسكو